how did you guys meet up like how did
you like end up you know hanging out
slitting her DM you know check you out
wreaths man gotta do it what was the
first DM now like what was like was it
like eyeballs was it nah she had she had
posted a um
what song was it
many Man by 50 Cent
she posted a picture and put mini man
like one of my fans had told me she was
following me and I didn't know who she
was to be honest like because you know
I'm not tapped into that world that she
was in you know what I mean I'm more I'm
I know about 50 Cent you know you know
what I'm saying all this [ __ ] that's
what I grew up listening to so you're
recording a joint album with blue face
let's be yeah that's what I'm saying so
I I wasn't in that world and then
somebody was like she's following you
[ __ ] man I'm like what was that so
when I tap in I do a bunch of little
research all right let me see so then
she posted like a picture of um
um herself playing many men in the
background and I was like oh that's a
nice song choice
now we're here you hit it with a nice
song Choice nice song choice and now
we're here that's great man nice song
Choice man and you're a great [ __ ]
guy sounds like both you guys are like
super super just like chill individuals
you know
salute to you